[Applaudissements]
in
marseille
[Musique]
toulon
ou encore paris pour ce huitième samedi
de mobilisation ils étaient encore
plusieurs milliers à battre le pavé dans
plus de 200 rassemblements partout en
france
cible de la vindicte depuis week end le
pass annie terre une mesure perçue comme
une entrave à la liberté pour les
manifestants présents dans les
différents cortèges je pense que là on a
ouvert la boîte de pandore et ce qui
m'inquiète en fait c'est pour ça que je
suis ici c'est surtout l'avenir
par exemple est ce que il faudra un jour
montrer qu'on a un passé sanitaire quand
on veut faire un emprunt bancaire voilà
donc là je trouve qu'on est dans une
dérive qui est très très inquiétante on
est pour les 99% des gens qui saurait
aussi mais on est des gens pacifistes on
veut juste scandé la liberté
la liberté d'être et de choisir tout
simplement je ne suis pas contre le
vaccin pas du tout mais que se vacciner
respecte les non vaccinés donc c'est la
liberté qui doit primer voilà et
j'aimerais bien que liberté fraternité
égalité
soit soit correspondent à quelque chose
aujourd'hui particulièrement attendu le
chiffre de la participation pour cette
première mobilisation depuis la rentrée
de septembre n'a pas connu le rebond
attendu selon les chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur les cortèges sont loin
d'avoir rassemblé autant de monde qu'au
coeur de l'été où le mouvement avait
rassemblé jusqu'à deux cent trente sept
mille personnes face à la multiplication
des personnes vaccinées près de 50
millions de français désormais
l'opposition peine à trouver le soutien
de l'opinion publique selon un dernier
sondage
67% des personnes interrogées approuvent
le pass and i ter pas découragé les
organisateurs appellent à une
mobilisation massive le 11 septembre
prochain en attendant la grève générale
prévue le 5 octobre à laquelle il espère
rejoindre leurs revendications
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]